bonsoir nicolas dupont aignan est
l'invité d'auditions publiques le
président de debout la france est avec
nous merci d'avoir répondu à
l'invitation des chaînes parlementaires
de l' agence france-presse et de figues
du figaro vous êtes bien sûr notre
invité alors que la france est plongée
dans une crise politique majeure on ne
voit toujours pas ce soir comment le
pays va en sortir le pire l'iton 1 n'est
pas exclue puisque il ya également des
contestations on le voit également dans
les cortèges sur le plan institutionnel
nicolas dupont aignan avait que moi ce
soir pour vous interroger anne renault
de la fp et istria du figaro on sent
déjà là pour la première partie de
l'émission lui aurait tout à l'heure les
journalistes oriane mancini et brigitte
se boucher de public sénat et de la
chaîne parlementaire assemblée nationale
et puis il y aura également dans environ
20 minutes maintenant
deux parlementaires sur ce plateau pour
dialoguer et vous interpellez également
le député la république en marche
r d'hébertville et le sénateur
socialiste jérôme durham et puis bien
sûr comme chaque semaine pour ceux qui
nous suivent sur le figaro live ils
peuvent intervenir bien sûr via le chat
poser leurs questions
eux aussi vous aussi vous pouvez
interpeller notre invité est bien sûr je
me ferais le relais de vos réflexions de
vos questions également nicolas dupont
aignan vous avez enfilé le gilet jaune
dès l'origine dès le 17 novembre dernier
et peut-être est-ce du mimétisme est en
tous les cas tout à l'heure vous avez
claqué la porte du bureau du premier
ministre
car la diffusion en direct sur facebook
vous a été refusée mais est-ce à la
hauteur de l'enjeu est digne d'un élu
écoutez la crise de confiance entre les
élus de la république et le peuple
français est totale j'étais content
d'aller voir le premier ministre j'ai
simplement demandé très poliment que cet
entretien qui allait parler des français
soit accessible aux français c'est tout
et je pensais que c'était un bon moyen
je pensais que c'était un bon moyen
justement de de renouer la confiance de
faire preuve de transparence c'est de la
démagogie
non non vous faites exactement
vous êtes un élu de la nation vous avez
été élu pour la nation et pour la
représenter et la détente vous comporter
comme des gilets jaunes parce que je
suis représentant du peuple
l'heure est grave et je suis convaincu
aussi et ils chacun reçu chacun fait ce
qu'il veut en tout cas j'estime est
fondamental que nous changions de
méthode que nous changions d'altitude
aucun irrespect je crois que l'heure est
grave
je crois que l'heure est grave et tout
ce qui sera fait pour montrer aux
français qu on est capable autour de la
table de parler sérieusement de
problèmes concrets tout ce qui sera fait
pour désamorcer une colère qui tourne à
la crise de régime sera positive cette
jeune a fait dans un métier invités risa
oui et alors pourquoi vous avez quoi
tourner les talons alors que personne
publique cet entretien mais si tu étais
une première tentative s'est pas c'est
pas dans les habitudes de la réplique
bien la république koivu et d'alex et de
transparence tu la transparence de 30
ans écouté il n'ya pas excès de
transparence dans notre république
sincèrement et je voudrais normes et au
delà de se refuser dès lors de l'acte je
ne refuse rien du tout j'aimais ma
portée je suis le sol une proposition de
loi que je dévoilerai dans la presse
demain à l'assemblée nationale que ce
soit sur vous quand même je vais vous en
parler mais une proposition de loi
concrètes cas avec mon parti politique
car quand même beaucoup moins de moyens
que l'état nous avons réussi en ce
week-end à analyser les propositions des
gilets jaunes retenir certaines écarter
d'autres et présenter un plan
financièrement équilibré qui permettrait
de sortir de la crise a encore les
jambes ou aux noix
non je n'ai pas le nom non parce que les
gilet jaune c'est le peuple français
dans sa diversité quelles propositions
majeures avez vous présenté est bien
retenue
d'ailleurs j'ai donné ce document
premiers minerais région et curieusement
il ya eu un dialogue sommes des gens
respectables
dialogue de deux minutes écoutez c'est
ce que je dois voir quoi j'ai proposé un
l'annulation des hausses de taxes au 1er
janvier que je propose d'ailleurs de
monde par des semaines oui le par la
junte édition à le dire mais je suis
ravie qu'enfin on les rejoint j'ai
proposé 2 de revenir en parler que des
taxes sur les carburants leur carburant
fioul gaz électricité l'ensemble 3
milliards et demi j'ai proposé de
revenir sur la hausse de la csg et la
désindexation des pensions de retraite
car c'est un une spoliation des
retraités et la rupture du contrat
social avec nos retraités qui ont
travaillé durement toute leur vie j'ai
proposé ensuite de revoir tout de suite
le statut des travailleurs détachés pour
que les travailleurs détachés étrangers
qui viennent sur notre sol paye les
charges sociales françaises
vous savez que c'est à des graves
problèmes graves problèmes de nos
artisans qui crèvent aujourd'hui dans le
pays
il y en à précision sur vos mesures
alors à l'impôt sur la fortune
non et du pouvoir parce que je quelque
chose que vous entendez dans les
manifestations ça j'ai proposé quelque
chose d'intermédiaire j'ai précis je
propose que l'impôt sur la fortune soit
rétablie mais qu'ils soient exonérés à
100% comme je l'avais proposé pour la
présidentielle pour les capitaux
réinvesti sur le sol français
c'était une mesure très intelligent
désolé de le dire
c'est très dangereux estime à six
personnes et en cours actuel oui mais
qui permettait de réconcilier les
français avec justement l'incitation à
produire en france
enfin dernier point je pète plus long
jeu propose car c'est fondamental et ça
renvoie à ce que j'ai essayé de faire
pour rendre publique cette audition le
référendum d'initiative populaire
j'avais fait une proposition
constitutionnel madame reno le sait il
ya quelques semaines avec jean louis
masson sénateur de la moselle pour
faciliter de référendum d'initiative
populaire qui existent en suisse en
italie aux états unis dans les états et
qui oxygène ray immensément notre
démocratie c'est ce que vous demandez
comme laurent wauquiez l'organisation
d'un référendum sur la transition
écologique
je vais vous dire je l'avais demandé le
référendum sur la transition écologique
mais je dirais que aujourd'hui
référendum sur quoi
c'est faire un référendum sur les taxes
qui ont été mises je vois pas le
président la république se faire hara
kiri
comme ça si c'est faire un référendum
sur un nouveau plan un contrat social
j'ai même proposé des états généraux de
la fiscalité
c'est à dire on remet tout à plat car je
me permets d'insister sur un point il
faut alléger la charge qui pèse sur ceux
qui travaillent en france mais il ne
faut pas déséquilibrer les finances
publiques alors justement dit vous avez
chiffré toutes les mesures que vous avez
bien sûr et ô combien je vous le
donnerai de danone en faut combien cela
publié non vous nous avez dit ce soir
les mesures nous c'était facile et je
vous en donnerai pas de quel est le
montant des mesures directes de et
quelles sont les contreparties
je lisais les lettres d'argent mais
d'ores et les arts d'euros milliards
d'euros où est ce que vous allez les
doors et décharné à 8 milliards d'euros
la dent d'ores et déjà si vous ne
répondez que sur une partie de vos
propositions ça ne va pas nicolas ils
vont ils vous aurez vous annoncer des
mesures sociales réclamées thème vous ne
nous dit pas où vous trouver l'argent
personne ne me dit que jamais mon
calendrier à bajaj allemand juillet moi
je vous redis comics 13 demain non mais
des tenailles et où est ce que vous
trouvez l'argent l'argent je le trouvais
le point fondamental justement à l'heure
où je peux vous répondre et du karaté au
public il faut réduire la dépense
publique mais au bon endroit et c'est ou
alors premièrement je mets fin à la
spoliation des français par l'union
européenne qui coûte une fortune aux
français sequans of milliards nets 9
milliards nets c'est notre contribution
au budget une contribution nette entre
ce qu'on verse est ce qu'on reçoit
c'était de 2 milliards il ya quelques
années ça a explosé
nous avons voté il ya trois semaines un
mois
enfin pas moi ça a été voté au parlement
une augmentation encore de 2 milliards
c'est sans fin et si on applique le
programme de l'union européenne
financier qui est en train d'être
discutées et qu'à accepter le président
macron quasiment il est prêt de donner
son feu vert
on passera 16 milliards nets c'est
considérable
je pense et ce sera un enjeu des
élections européennes qu'il faut cesser
de dépenser autant pour une organisation
qui nous fait du mal
attendez attendez attendez je finis
là-dessus ce que c'est très important
sur ces 9 milliards net on peut
récupérer entre 5 et 6 milliards très
vite que j'effectuerai aux retraités ce
qui a été pris aux retraités à travers
la csg je le rendrai aux retraités en
prenant l'excès de contribution à
l'union européenne nous sommes le
deuxième contributeur net
oui bon c'est une augmentation
considérable est génial c'est sur un
autre chiffre qui ne sont pas les vôtres
et qui m'attire depuis l'arrêt de
commissions était légal et ça par
exemple aux agriculteurs aux éleveurs
qui demandent de vous par une lette
beaucoup la loi la politique agricole
commune
excusez moi mais si je peux reprendre
oui tu gros surprenante en europe
n'enléve orient c'est la première
équation les agriculteurs la france
reçoit 22 23 milliards de dépenses 22 23
milliards - 9 milliards il reçoit lyon
marty ça n'enlève rien notre
contribution était exorbitant du droit
commun on ne peut pas continuer je
rappelle que l'angleterre avait
bénéficié d'un rabais dichotomie pris
l'argent j'ai une autre oui mais j'ai
une autre solution
oui mais attendez on va en parler
comment expliquez-vous que là on est
d'accord ou pas avec vous vous avez des
propositions qui sont en distorsion
complète avec votre attitude de cet
après midi cet après midi vous allez
voir le premier ministre vous dites on a
on peut pas je peux pas être
enregistrées je m'en vais c'est en
distorsion avec la l'offre de dialogue
que vous lui faites et qu'il vous faire
est le grand cinéma
moi je ne fais pas de cinéma je suis
journaliste je vous avoue c'est la
question les x c'est quand même étonnant
quoi on a cherché je finis sur les
finances parce que je suis quelqu'un
c'est libre et je réponds le premier ni
sait lire je lui ai remis mon document
il est écrit chemin des soldats et rares
hommes politiques quand il a un
entretien françois hollande s'en moquait
sont amusés avec moi quand ils me
recevait à l'elysée d'où est le seul qui
apportait toujours un dossier
je dis oui parce que je travaille donc
je lui ai remis un dossier précis je
fais une différence de presse demain
ce que je veux c'est auquel soyons pris
c'est montrer aux français qu'on peut
sortir de cette crise par le haut c'est
à dire par des propositions concrètes
financées
j'ai pas parlé de la taxe sur les
transactions financières
mik attendez un instant j'ai pas parlé
de la taxe sur les gaffes à qu'on peut
mettre en place j'ai pas parlé de la
taxe sur le fuel des bateaux qui
accostent dans notre pays et qui amène
ses marchandises qui nous coûtent une
fortune en termes de co2 je n'ai pas
encore parlé du paiement des camions qui
traversent la france qui devront avec
moi payer une taxe quand en allemagne il
y a des recettes ont fait croire aux
français qu'il n'y a pas de recette le
smic sur le smic c'est plus compliqué je
vais être franc avec vous parce que je
crois que le smic doit augmenter mais ne
peut le faire que progressivement si on
est capable de baisser les charges sur
les pme car augmenter le smic sans
baisser la charge sur le pmu c'est
condamner nos entreprises donc vous
donnera je ne suis pas un
vous êtes je suis un modéré vous êtes
dans la proposition concrète et vous
demandez pas la démission du président
de la république
mais pourquoi je demanderai la digestion
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale
alors je vais vous réponds si la crise
s'aggrave si le gouvernement répond à la
souffrance des français par des
cacahuètes ou des miettes la crise
s'aggravera way est obligatoirement
l'arbitrage du peuple sera nécessaire
vraiment 1968
parce que il ya un moment s'il n'y a pas
une sortie politique capable calme et
l'insurrection
car c'est une forme d'insurrection il
faudra l'arbitrage avant la fin place de
mons à ce que j'attendais pourquoi je
fais des propositions concrètes parce
que je crois qu'avant de dire
dissolution dissolution thé mission tout
ça ça n'a pas de sens si d'abord en tant
qu'homme politique responsable on
n'essaye pas alors d'apporter sa pierre
à la g
on estime avoir reste président d'accor
si en revanche le président de la
république et le gouvernement reste dans
leurs petits calculs
alors oui je dis que malheureusement
viendra le moment où les français
voudront s'exprimer par les urnes
pour éviter que la colère soit dans la
rue parce qu'on vous le considérez comme
légitimes humain je suis républicain il
a été élu au suffrage universel
elle j'ai été candidat à la
présidentielle je respecte les
institutions de la république et j'ai ce
prime
écoutez je vais respecte profondément et
c'est parce que justement ces
institutions de la république sont
totalement hors sol le coupé de toute
réalité que j'essaye à ma façon en fait
partie à écouter
j'ai été l'un des rares à ne pas
soutenir macron à plat ventre comme
monsieur fillon comme l'ensemble des
élèves qui ont été votées macron donc eu
comme monsieur mélenchon moi j'ai pris
mes responsabilités au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
alors on ne peut me suspecter d'avoir
favorisé les rues dit de vous même
nicolas dupont aignan je suis un homme
politique responsable
oui tout vous dites même je suis modéré
mais on entend quand même d'autres
choses sur vous un par exemple laurent
berger qui vous a trouvé délirant ce
week-end et puis la question est celle
ci au monsieur verger savais que je veux
dire ce que me sur des cibles et bergers
est il est quoi eh bien chacun salue son
sens des responsabilités son appel audio
je vais vous dire c'est terrible
monsieur bergé est aux abonnés absents
il a discrédité le syndicalisme comme
jamais puisque en fait il ya une crise
sociale majeure mais plutôt qu'ils ont
disparu mais martin est ce pareil quand
on sait qu'aux débutants mais soyons
mais je vais l'intérieur une question
arthur la radicalité
quand la cgt quand le mouvement énergie
à sont pas les miens
donc faut pas y aller mais est ce qu'ils
se rendent compte que ceux qui sont sur
les barrages
ce sont des infirmières ce sont des
ouvriers
ce sont des chauffeurs de taxi ce sont
des artisans ce sont des femmes
retraitées
je les ai rencontrés se sont pas des
révolutionnaires non mes volets en bois
pour avis il assume désormais on
comprend leur souffrance sociale
il assume aussi une part de radicalité
nauséeux sinon si on loi une
radicalisation d'un gilet jaune mari oui
alors ça c'est la grande et lire qu'à
essayer d'abord d'instrumentaliser le
gouvernement les gilet jaune moi je les
connais je les connais j'en ai vu
nationaux mais nous aussi on les connaît
ménagé ses bas enfin ça a été la grande
manoeuvre du gouvernement qui a cru
qu'il pouvait laisser des quatre soeurs
cassé et que par un retournement de
l'opinion et de belles images
les français là se souvient aurélie
gilet jaune non traitement très pas bon
on les a vus pourtant vous accusé de
manipulations ah oui d'organisation même
d'organiser attendait pas tous en même
temps parce que sinon les c'est une
mobilisation exceptionnelle des faits
oui jamais demandé la démission de ce
cas ces dernières attendent et nous
prenons les choses par ordre dans
l'ensemble du pays
vous avez des centaines des milliers de
barrages filtrage de gens qui n'ont
jamais manifesté de la france qui
travaille qui ne demandent que la
récompense de l'effort et du mérite
et voilà pourquoi je suis à leurs côtés
et c'est gilet jaune pacifique n'ont
rien alors avoir lieu avec les scènes de
quincieux minaj du point qu'on a besoin
pas seulement la toile dans d'autres
villes de province
art est tombé sur des gens kayes
disons-le armes à la main qu'un
emballage
il n'a rien à voir arrêtons avant de
disserter s mais ça interesse samedi ce
que vous appeler à manifester si des
réponses satisfaisantes à vos beaux yeux
ne sont pas donnés d'ici à samedi
j'appelle soyons précis où es tu j'ai
dit pas de manifestation aux champs
elysées d'accord il faut arrêter bon
j'ai dit en revanche que les gilet jaune
devait rester positionnés dans tout le
pays pour exprimer la souffrance d'un
peuple qui n'en peut plus d'être spoliés
d'être rackettés par un essaim qui
travaillent qui des deux villes
concernées il y a eu sa dérive et ça a
dégénéré
donc en disant pas les champs-elysées
mais ailleurs ça peut très bien
dégénérer jeu qu'est ce qui se passe
parce que voulait faire un coup est ce
que vous voulez un couvre-feu l'état
d'urgence si laborieusement avait
protégé l'arc de triomphe qui a été
protégé le 24 novembre qui ne l'a pas
été ce coup ci
si le gouvernement s'attaquer vraiment
aux anarchistes qu'on connaît ces fameux
black
les compagnies bloc qui ont été à la
manoeuvre
chaque week-end c'est le travers maman
était beaucoup plus sévères sur la
petite racaille des banlieues qui vient
piller
après chaque manifestation on n'en
serait pas là je galère et imprimera que
vous dites est un pompier pyromane
je l'accuse gravement d'avoir été soit
incompétent soit cynique
est ce que ce qui est beaucoup plus
grave encore c'est qu'en laissant cette
violence se propager pour discréditer
les gilet jaune
il a alimenté une nouvelle violence et
maintenant vous avez de la racaille qui
vient et qui se greffent sur les
manifestations au risque de plonger
notre pays dans un chaos dont contre la
ville la violence elle est le fait de
groupes organisés que l'on connaît et
qu'est ce qu'on fait samedi prochain à
paris sur les charniers dans les faits
on peut tout à fait s'attaquer aux black
bloc et c'est curieux c'est toujours la
même méthode avec monsieur macro et
monsieur castaner 1
on a eu sa le 1er mai c'est même
monsieur benalla qui était à leurs yeux
la réponse est la même qui lance vous
avez vu le nombre des interpellés dans
ces interpellés la plupart sont pas du
tout des black blocks sont pas des gens
de l'ultra droite il y a eu ce sont des
gens qui viennent de province qui son
père de famille vision oui mais mais qui
sait dire légitime pas séduisant violent
mais je vais vous dire une chose 207
vous soutenez il ya une image non je
soutiens une colère populaire légitime
et j'apporte des solutions justement
pour éviter et qui bloque aujourd'hui
c'est le gouvernement qui est
responsable de cette violence j'ajoute
un point il ya une photo qu'on n'a pas
vu tiens j'aurais aimé la voir à la une
du figaro
mais je voulais peut-être mieux vaut
états nous ont fait pas appel à la
violence quelle photo une belle photo de
tous les gilet jaune qui protégeait la
tombe du soldat inconnu
c'était une photo très émouvante parce
qu'ils les gilets jaunes se sont
mobilisés pour protéger la tombe du
soldat inconnu contre des casseurs qui
ont été laissées là alors c'est
lamentable cette fois bien on n'a pas eu
beaucoup si on l'a vu on a vu apparaître
entrevue on
mon travail avec d'autres mais en tout
cas montré la marque allemande
on ne doit pas dresser les français les
uns contre les autres et le rôle d'un
gouvernement permettez moi c'est pas
d'essayer de manipuler des casseurs
contre le peuple
c'est d'essayer de trouver une solution
de sortie de crise raisonnable pas trop
coûteuse financièrement qui répartit la
charge différemment l'âge alors c'est la
fin de cette séquence antique mais c'est
cette semaine à cette semaine allez
merci merci aux convives
anne c'est la deuxième partie de
l'émission maintenant d'audition qg
qu'avec les deux parlementaires qui font
leur entrée sur le plateau nicolas
dupont aignan pour vous interrogé plus
avant encore
bonsoir messieurs donc hervé berville
bonsoir vous êtes député la république
en marge des côtes d'armor est à vos
côtés
jérôme durain que sénateur socialiste de
saône et loire une question des
internautes qui nous suivent sur le
figaro live quelqu'un vous demande
suite à vos déclarations à l'instant et
puis à votre acte
certains diront votre coup médiatique à
matignon nicolas dupont aignan est ce
que vous allez donc désormais rendre
public est filmé tout vous rendez vous
moi je peux en fils mais beaucoup oui en
tout cas quand il ya une situation grave
nous ne polémiquons pas là dessus quand
il ya une situation aussi grave
une telle crise de confiance tous qui
permettra
comment dire d'avoir un peu plus de
démocratie directe d'avoir un peu plus
de transparence d'associer les français
sera positif
le référendum d'initiative populaire je
le réclame depuis tant d'années la
reconnaissance du vote blanc
le casier judiciaire vierge qui avait
été promis par emmanuel macron cam a été
fait tout ça c'est tellement important
alors vous savez on peut se moquer de
moi mais moi à ma façon avec les moyens
que j'ai j'alerte la classe politique
sur la nécessité d'agir autrement c'est
tout oui je ne veux pas être baladés par
des consultations qui durerait des
semaines alors qu'il ya le feu à la
maison france
et eux les images qu'on a vu de par le
monde sont pas dégradantes simplement
pour les gilet jaune qui sont des gens
de bonne foi
elles sont dégradantes pour tout le pays
et on joue pas avec le feu on joue pas
avec une nation aussi en difficulté
aussi en colère que la france la france
quand elle est martyrisée elle est
violente mais bien il faut éviter ça
vous entendiez de la martyrisé vous
entendez ces propos comment est-ce que
vous réagissez monsieur le sénateur et
ensuite monsieur le député qui aura
peut-être à coeur de défendre les
options qui sont jusque là défendue par
l'exécutif
j'écoutais nicolas dupont aignan avec
intérêt depuis tout à l'heure alors il
me dit
la crise est profonde il faut pas jouer
avec le feu il je suis républicain mais
en même temps puisque cette circonstance
vous enfiler un gilet jaune vous accuser
le gouvernement de manipulation vous
fait un esclandre cet après midi chez le
premier ministre est ce que vous n'avez
pas le sentiment quand même
nicolas dupont aignan que cette façon de
faire de la vieille politique
les vieux coup les effets de manche ou
alors d'importer dans le champ de la
politique nationale
une forme de tropisme ça répond vraiment
à l'urgence de la situation à ce que je
n'ai pas le sentiment que les françaises
vers d'autres choses et qu'à côté de la
colère sociale qui s'exprime
il ya une exigence démocratique est ce
que vous proposez ce que vous faites là
dans cette crise c'est pas du tout à la
hauteur des enjeux
écoutez je vous remets très demain
puisque vous allez la recevoir comme
collègue la proposition de loi que j'ai
rédigé tout le week-end avec le sénateur
masson il vos collègues que vous
connaissez bien sénateur de la moselle
on a travaillé tout le week-end avec nos
assistants et on a écrit des
propositions très concrètes
reprenant d'ailleurs des propositions de
loi constitutionnelle que j'avais déjà
adressé pour essayer de changer les
choses
vous savez je pourrais crier comme
certains mâcon démission ou dissolution
je n'y crois pas je crois que c'est pas
ça l'enjeu
l'enjeu c'est que chacun à sa façon on
propose des solutions
moi j'ai le courage de proposer des
solutions à partir de là libre à chacun
de juger mon comportement une chacun
fait à sa façon
j'essaie depuis un certain temps dans la
vie politique quand j'ai soulevé les
barrières d'autoroute pour dénoncer la
spoliation des autoroutes devait lutter
contre la spoliation des autoroutes je
pense le racket des français sur les
autoroutes ça continue depuis 2006 alors
même si vous me donnez une autre méthode
est ce que vous croyez
j'ai rencontré à arles une retraitée 72
ans toute la nuit sur des barrages elle
me dit monsieur vous crois que ça me
fait plaisir des sous la pluie dans le
froid la bloquer une route aurait elle
fait ça pour quoi
quand le système démocratique ne
fonctionne plus non mais là c'est là la
seule chose bord je suis passé sur 72
sur la dame de 76 ans nous vraiment très
bien compassion là non
surveillons b nous avons tous le même
respect ne l'a même écho tenu la
question sur votre conduite
j'entendais sur l'image des politiques
et images des politiques je pense que
c'est plutôt l'image de monsieur marc
macron qui a insulté les français depuis
qu'il est élu régulièrement qui est
beaucoup plus grave que ce que je peux
faire pour alerter le pouvoir politique
aveugle sur la situation ne renversons
pas les rôles quand monsieur mac ronde
ya un chômeur traverse la route et du
terroir du boulot quand ils traitent les
français de d'alcooliques de grincheux
de gloire réfractaires j'entre écoutez
donc vous savez être président de la
république sait rassembler la nation et
c'est lui donner une vision sa seule
vision c'est de servir ceux qui l'ont
élu
c'est à dire eux les gros donateurs de
londres voilà qui ont donné beaucoup
d'argent on a maintenant les résultats
de ses donateurs
on sait qui a payé la campagne vers
merville alors il faut intervenir
je veux dire les choses mais il faut
dire les choses et vous avez raison j'ai
hâte servir vos propositions je recevrai
j'aurai les airs pendant la même
commission donc je devrais je regarderai
avec beaucoup d'attention je pense que
vous avez dit quelque chose qui est vrai
c'est qu'il faut rassembler les français
mais ce que vous faites l'attitude que
vous avez depuis trois quatre cinq jours
c'est pas du tout une attitude qui vise
à rassembler des français vous jute et
la suspicion notamment sur le premier
ministre en disant je refuse de
participer à cette réunion
parce qu'elle n'est pas filmé mais vous
saviez très bien quand vous alliez
rentrer dans cette réunion qu'elle ne
serait pas nécessaire mais revenez c'est
la première fois je voulais entendre
monsieur dupont tenir je demande la zone
filmé et moi je rejoins les intendants
des gilets jaunes
oui mais attendez c'est pas parce que
les gilets jaunes demande quelque chose
mais c'est que l'intelligent pour une
fois non mais attendez vous savez très
bien et dans ce cas là j'attends de voir
que vous allez du coup maintenant film
et tous vos rendez vous toutes vos
réunions moi j'ai deux remarques à faire
je vous ai écouté attentivement je sais
vous êtes un homme sérieux vous avez été
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
c'est que je vois beaucoup de
propositions même si on les a pas toutes
aussi sur la table et moi ce qui je
trouve qu'ils manquent dans l'analyse
c'est la question de la transformation
de l'action publique la question de la
dépense publique et moi j'ai rencontré
comme vous j'imagine un certain nombre
de gilet jaune à ma permanence pendant
quatre heures et ils m'ont parlé de ça
ils ont l'impression que l'état n'est
plus forcément lisible que ça fait vingt
trente ans que les prélèvements
obligatoires au monde
sachez le bien et vous êtes au courant
vous étiez en responsabilité aussi
j'ai été tués depuis 2002 oui je n'ai
pas soutenu et j'ai combattu özil en
savoie en 4 à 10 je demande une autre
politique
oui on peut me rendre grâce au moins
mais vous voyez bien que de l'arbre une
arrivée avec constance une autre
politique depuis des années peut-être
parce que c'est cette politique de
l'union européenne à laquelle obéissent
servilement tous les gouvernements
depuis 20 ans qui nous a placé le peuple
français dans cet état de leur mrc
délégation si vous avez entendu et nous
avons fondé notre invité ils ont raison
mais où il a raison et là je peux j'ai
regardé ce que vous dites et malgré ce
que vous faites il n'y a pas de
proposition sur la transformation de
l'action plus vite non alors il est de 2
2e ensuite c'était sur l'union
européenne
vous vouliez au soir du premier tour des
élections présidentielles être le
premier ministre de marine le pen et
maintenant on y voit là je pense qu'on
serait dans une situation que vit bien
plus catastrophiques je ne crois pas et
on n'aurait pas le gain de pouvoir
d'achat qui a eu kéba pas assez fort
pour nos concitoyens qu'il faut
continuer non mais attendez
entre 2008 et 2016 nos concitoyens par
ménage ont perdu 440 euros en moyenne
ça a commencé à diminuer depuis 2007
c'était en fait c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est vince est et ce qu'il faut faire
mieux oui est ce qu'il faut aller
beaucoup plus vite
oui mais vous ne pouvez pas non plus
vous affranchir de vos responsabilités
puisque ça fait plus de vingt ans que
vous êtes aux responsabilités on vous
avait il est moi si je ne suis pas aux
responsabilités j'ai voté contre tous
est budgétée dans la majorité non non
vous trompez vous avez fait campagne à
biner ministériel vous trompez vous
trompez je peux avoir le kremlin j'ai
encore le droit de savoir ce que j'ai
fait ce que j'ai voté j'ai quitté l'ump
solennellement après ce trafic à sion
scandaleuse du traité de lisbonne qui
reprenait le traité que les français
avaient rejeté en 2005 qui nous a
plongés dans ce moins disant social
économique
ce désastre économique de la fin de la
production française industriels qui
explique la crise actuelle et on peut
tout dire de moi mais on ne peut pas
nier la cohérence de mes propos depuis
des années j'ai proposé une politique
protectionniste jeu
repose une politique où on arrête d'être
line un jardin de l'allemagne je propose
une reconfigurer à sion de l'europe
autour d'un tarif douanier commun de ce
que fait trump aux états unis oui ce
qu'a fait le japon je fonce à c'est très
intéressant je considère qu'il ya une
autre politique économique amené
l'italie est en train de l'amener tant
mieux et d'autres pays vont l'amener
avec ambition sur l'a86 dans ce que je
veux vous dire chers collègues
on peut être en désaccord mais au moins
reconnaissez qu'il ya une cohérence
quand je j'ai développé la
présidentielle l'idée dû produire en
france avec une incitation fiscale à
produire en france et une taxation
notamment du carbone qui vient des
produits qui viennent de milliers de
kilomètres en 2007 vous avez signé le
pacte de monsieur hulot je les signe est
minuit je n'avais pas relu le pack 2007
ce nombre est sinon monsieur gossio
dresser un bilan je réponds parce que
les téléspectateurs peuvent croire
répond d'échangé du lot de 2007 que j'ai
signé il parlait la taxe carbone et
notamment de la taxe carbone aux
frontières pour éviter ce libre échange
fou
vous avez signé le c'est à monsieur
macron hassine il s'éteint le traité de
libre-échange avec le canada qui n'est
toujours pas ratifiée par la france
vous êtes dans une logique de libre
échange déloyal qui fait que notre pays
est en train de crever dans la plus
belle ville vous répondez d'un mot
surdoué mais au moins j'ai une cohérence
vous avez la vôtre je vous entretenais
cohérent ce que dans les services ni les
républicains sur cohérent nous sommes
cohérents
après chacun savait rien de lui et je ne
lui ai pas encore je dis simplement s'il
faut prendre la taxe carbone attentes
hier jeudi vous avez évolué depuis que
vous êtes et mais c'est tout à votre
honneur de jolies et de changer de
position
j'ai essayé contre 97 mais bon on va
partir de la sélection juste sur le
commerce sur le commerce
moi je la question la guerre commerciale
on le voit bien actuellement entre les
etats-unis et la chine ça qu'est ce que
ça apporte n'apporte absolument rien du
tout d'abord de lancer aux américains
vous savez non non ça n'a pas d'emploi
pour l'instant aux états unis ni aux
chinois d'ailleurs et bien une chose que
vous avez très bien
c'est la question de la réciprocité si
on se lance dans une guerre commerciale
comment faire nos concurrents me
partenaires ils vont faire exactement de
choses et je vous dirai simplement une
chose parce que la bretagne celle de
juin des côtes d'armor
c'est une terre qui exporte pas mal un
emploi sur trois dans le secteur privé
en france est liée à des activités à
l'international c'est beaucoup beaucoup
d'emplois et donc si on fait une guerre
commerciale qui se double en général
d'une guerre monétaire
on arrive à ralentir du commerce à
ralentissement de l'activité économique
ce sont mes côtés j'ai honnêtement vous
allez répondre votre décision
internationale du commerce et sur votre
cohérence bon vous vous revendiquez ce
soir marine le pen c'était non oui non
et puis aujourd'hui vous nous dites que
ça aurait été mieux avec elle le vote
cohérence n'est pas toujours très
lisibles et d'ailleurs votre parcours
récent cette cohérence je considère pas
qu'elle saute aux yeux
ce qui nous vaut d'ailleurs des
différences de fond s'agissant du
produire en france enfin moi je viens
pas de bretagne je viens de saône et
loire pour un ministre il y avait un
ministre en saône et loire qui s'appelle
arnaud montebourg sur ces questions de
produire en france de médine france on
était assez bien placé il avait renvoyé
moi ce que je vote président l'a
renvoyée
moi ce que je considère quand même sur
cette affaire là tu sais que
l'apologie du libre échange qui vient de
nous être fait ou l'apologie du prix de
la sortie de l'europe que que vous
souhaitez faire elles ne sont pas
ratifié par les français les gilets
jaunes
vous l'aurez remarqué il ya une colère
sociale une aspiration démocratique
toutes les autres questions elles ont
disparu donc quand vous dites quand vous
étiez de resituer la question européenne
dans le champ des lits gilet jaune ça ne
fonctionne pas parce que objectivement
ce que les gens attendent c'est d'abord
lise jsf la fin bien c'est le seul sujet
sur lequel finalement vous ne vous
exposez pas nous aussi on fait une
proposition à les socialistes une
proposition de loi
on parle de l'annulation des taxes on
parle de la fin de l' isf on parle du
chèque énergie qui va être améliorée une
csg qui disparaît pour tout ce qu'elle
pénalise en dessous de 3000 euros de
retraite voilà c'est les mesures
sociales mais il ya aussi la question
démocratique et moi je vous trouve sur
cet aspect là pas la hauteur des enjeux
l'éditeur vous êtes dans une forme de
provocation
on a eu la provocation macro nist mac
reviennent avec ses petites phrases vous
les avez rappelé vous avez raison il ya
une dimension personnelle dans la crise
et d'ailleurs les maquereaux démission
c'est une sanction cas personnel du
président la république n'est d'accord
on est d'accord sur ce point il est là
pour rassembler il ne l'a pas fait je
trouve que dans mon temps que posture
vous ne rassemblez pas non plus et que
la sortie de crise la crise elle est
grave
les élus sont inquiets tous à tous les
niveaux j'en ai vu ce week-end beaucoup
tout le monde est inquiet je pense qu'il
faut apaiser les choses alors alors si
je tiendrai compte parce que jusque là
mais répondent sur le côté rassembleur
je peux quand même région vient
d'entendre la question en substance
c'est est-ce que vous fermez est-ce
qu'on peut rassembler aux extrêmes mais
qu'elle soit par les d'extrait dernier
n'est pas d'accord avec la la pensée
unique de notre pays depuis vingt ans on
et d'extrémistes donc sur la sphère
politique
j'ai fait mon choix du second tour est
de plus en plus de français comprennent
pourquoi j'avais fait ce choix pour
autant je reste totalement indépendant
de madame le pen j'ai fait un choix
comme monsieur fillon a soutenu en
marche
comme beaucoup de mes fonctions en large
et changera malheureusement nos échanges
on vous échangez ans né en
responsable c'est à dire qu'est ce que
vous n'avez des rires des jeux si je
peux prendre dans l'ordre donc je veux
répondre là-dessus ce que je suis franc
deuxièmement sur la réponse sociale je
suis pour la justice sociale est c'est
fait bien sûr je suis pour le
rétablissement d'un isf mais avec
déduction
quand on investit en france en faire
levier de production française mais je
dis et c'est je crois l'honneur de mon
parti debout la france est de ceux qui
m'accompagnent que ce n'est pas
suffisant parce que on ne peut partager
qu'un gâteau qui se développent et je
dis que tant qu'on continuera à accepter
un libre échange déloyal le libre
échange c'est sain je suis pas pour des
barrières protectionnistes
je suis simplement pour faire ce que
tous les pays du monde développé fond le
libre échange oui quand il est loyal et
je n'accepte pas ce diktat d'une
commission européenne qui fait que notre
industrie a été laminée depuis 20 ans
quelques gouvernements que ce soit parce
que on a accepté que la chine notamment
triche avec toutes les règles et ce à
l'échelle européenne mais ça suffise à
se voiler chercheur eben mais tu peux
finit bien sûr ça se joue à l'échelle
européenne et nationale mais c'est la
france continue à voir disparaître
toutes ces industries à accepter que des
travailleurs détachés travail sur son
sol sans payer les charges sociales
françaises
eh bien vous aurez de plus en plus de
gilet jaune parce que j'ai vu sur les
barricades entre guillemets énormément
de chefs de pme d'artisans de petits
cadres qui ont compris l'arnaqué et ce
n'est pas être ultra protectionnistes
que simplement demandé que notre pays se
défendent et c'est ainsi qu'on re
constituera une base productive
notamment avec la proposition que
j'avais faite pendant la présidentielle
très concrète que je remets dans les
propositions que je vais vous envoyer
demain division par 2 de l'impôt sur les
sociétés pour les bénéfices réinvestis
sur leur sol français il ya rien qu'à
l'échec de monsieur macron depuis un an
et demi c'est quoi c'est qu'il a déversé
des milliards d'euros aux plus riches de
france sans qu'il y est
aucun ruissellement sur la capacité
productive du pib revêche observateurs
et j'en suis sûr r-vrd vous avez entendu
deux attendait et c'est à des jambes
n'est pas retombée sur les français
d'alors tellement fermé vers les landais
coutu large ans et une interpellation
gelé sinon ils n'en peuvent plus que
c'est si rationnelle
votre politique est déjà un échec
changer de politique avant qu'il soit
trop tard jean j'ai vite mais monsieur
avant que les français changent de
président en parler c'est dans l'avenir
et c'est moi terminer demain je vous
expliquerai oui il va emmener le pays
vous ne pouvez ne pas être d'accord mais
au moins laissez moi louis le temps d'y
répondre sur la question on entend tout
le temps ça que ce soit à gauche ou à
droite et la théorie du ruissellement
mais non parce qu'on répète 50 fois un
mensonge que ça deviendrait une vérité
est tellement extraordinaire mais
personne ne me croit moi le premier à la
théorie du ruissellement ce qu'on dit
simplement et vous l'avez dit non
personnes interrogées mais du présent
dans public le premier de cordée qu'ils
adressent à n'a rien à voir avec la
théorie du ruissellement tirer et puis
les deux dire que en donnant plus
d'argent aux usa mais celui que les gc -
termine à matane et recevrez votre
encaissé quelque chose les meilleurs
tubes qu'on entend les stands ce qui est
ce qui est sûr et vous l'avez dit parce
qu'on a perdu deux de l'outil productif
on sait pas suffisamment moderniser on a
laissé filer d'entreprise d'industrie
depuis 40 ans on n'a pas forcément est
suffisamment investi donc qu'est ce que
l'on a fait avec la question de l' isf
il ya toujours un impôt sur la fortune
immobilière mais sur l'autre partie on a
dit quoi on a dit on va libérer ce
capital pour que les personnes qui ont
des peines capitales puisse être
investis qu'est ce qui s'est passé cette
année en 2018 c'est pas des
carabistouilles que je vous raconte ce
sont des chiffres concrets plus de 60 5%
d'investissement cette année dans les
pme et les start up
non mais je termine juste ça
cette année également plus 30%
d'investissement dans les robots vers
verwilghen qu'est-ce que je termine je
suis d'accord il faut évaluer l'honneur
de du parlement c'est d'évaluer les
mesures et donc dans deux ans on fera
une évaluation mais il vous invite
les deux interlocuteurs sur ce plateau
dire à propos d' emmanuel macron de
celui-ci et dans l'opinion publique
un sentiment de m vous l'avez entendu et
les deux l'on dit est ce que dans ces
conditions là comment le chef de l'état
peut s'en sortir si vraiment il n'aspire
cela est ce que vous le ressentez vous
même j'ai une partie des oppositions qui
souffle sur brest n'a pas attendu
situation aussi grave dire des choses
comme ça ça me va bien parce que ça
n'est pas la réalité parce que je pense
qu'on est au mois ou six responsables
légitimes a commencé non c'est trop
musée toile a chassé de l'élection c'est
faux on a un certain nombre de
responsables politiques à dire qu'il est
léger et on est un certain nombre de
responsables politiques à dire qu'il y a
eu avec l'arrivée à nîmes à une accro un
espoir
cet espoir il a été déçu c'était une
tromperie cette année et demie elle est
gâchée est donc comment on en sort donc
ne nous dit pas que nous souffrons sur
le pass et nous nous faisons de travail
d'opposant quand supportait pas le rend
assez comme on le voit au parlement si
je peux mais non monsieur prix
d'amérique c'est ce qu'on va arrêter la
séquence en fait on a plus de temps mais
côté certain nombre d'oppositions et
c'est normal qu'on toujours pas digéré
le fait que les gagner l'élection
présidentielle et législatives
en français on les écoute on les entend
et on modifie qu'on ya besoin versé les
modifier pour vous et il a fortiori
pendant les autres questions merci merci
merci d'être venus participer à cet
échange ce dialogue parfois compliqué et
on va compliquer ses loyers est parfois
un peu tendu au ralenti vous convient
c'est l'honneur de la démocratie
c'est pour ça que nous sommes tous ce
soir à vous suivre
merci c'est la dernière partie tout de
suite de l'émission qui arrive avec et
brigitte boucher et oriane mancini
avec une question d'heures en attendant
vont soir mesdames une questions des
internautes du figaro live nicolas
dupont aignan est ce que vous n'êtes pas
finalement un peu en phase avec la
démarche italienne avec le projet
budgétaire italien c'est à dire est ce
que vous ne souhaitez pas encore
augmenter la dette publique avec
toujours plus de déficits c'est la
question qui vous est posée
non je pense qu'il faut dépenser
autrement qui a beaucoup d'économies à
faire notamment l'aide aux migrants qui
est excessive aux clandestins deux
milliards supplémentaires l'augmentation
du budget de l'union européenne j'en ai
parlé des économies dans le
fonctionnement de l'état
donc on peut réduire la dépense publique
sur beaucoup de choses
et puis on peut réduire les taxes qui
pèsent sur le travail en france et
l'automobile est un élément du travail
est en revanche on doit taxer la
concurrence déloyale ce que je veux tout
simplement mais c'est tellement du bon
sens c'est que on arrête de massacrer
fiscalement ceux qui sont en france sur
le territoire français pour exonérer de
taxe tous ceux qui vendent des produits
dans notre pays et qui ainsi détruisent
la valeur du travail dans notre pays et
c'est pourquoi je suis un peu différent
des italiens encore que en italie il ya
une baisse de l'impôt pour re inciter à
produire mais moi mon programme et
c'était le programme de ma
présidentielle produire en france tout
ce qui contribue à la travail français
ont des taxes tout ce qui vient en
concurrence déloyale on re taxes on
rééquilibre les choses mais c'est du bon
sens option le député des intérêts
évidemment réciprocité immédiate bombe
alors on va pas comptable avait débouché
peau c'est que ce que je répondrai pas
sur le mouvement d'aidé gilet jaune
devant soir nicolas dupont aignan le
- des gels et jaune en tout cas les
représentants n'iront pas à matignon
demain on a appris ça tout à l'heure
comment peuvent-ils faire des
revendications et refuser le dialogue
écouter ne demandons pas aux gilets
jaunes d'être ce qu'ils ne sont pas ce
sont des personnes de bonne volonté
d'opinion très différentes qui se sont
rassemblés et ses seins heureusement
qu'ils sont là pour dire on n'en peut
plus de travailler pour rien on n'en
peut plus de cette injustice mais ils
sont pacifiques à sion doit répondre le
premier ministre et le président la
république puisque on ne sait pas
exactement ce qu'elle veut accorder
arrêtons on les connaît par coeur ses
revendications la première revendication
c'est qu'au 1er janvier c'est dans moins
d'un mois
trois milliards et demi supplémentaire
de taxes vont s'abattre sur les français
qui veulent remplir leurs cuves de fuel
pour se chauffer qui veulent prendre
leur voiture pour aller travailler
qui vole le utiliser leur camionnette
pour livrer un produit et ses français
ne peuvent déjà même plus payer les
taxes qu'on leur annonce est depuis des
années envers d'achat donc attendez
premier point essayons de moi si j'étais
au pouvoir j'essaierai de prendre les
problèmes les uns après les autres
c'est comme un mikado il faut enlever
chaque petite petite pièce du mikado
pour éviter que tout s'écroule
donc déjà est ce que le gouvernement au
lieu de reculer de faire des manoeuvres
dilatoires d' est ce qu'il pourrait pas
dire un moment j'ai mis trop de oui on a
été trop loin
on revoit on s'arrête au 1er janvier on
va souffler vous allez pouvoir offrir un
cadeau à vos enfants de noël plutôt que
de remplir une taxe supplémentaire un
peu de paix un peu d'humanité c'est
juste un moratoire non on arrête ces
taxes monstrueuse qui empêche les gens
de travailler
premier point deuxième point on revoit
la situation de nos retraités car le
gouvernement a eu la main trop lourde et
ya une façon très simple sans revenir
sur la csg comme je le propose sans
aller jusque-là rétablir la dégustation
des pensions de retraite sur l'inflation
je vous rappelle qu'aucun gouvernement
depuis la libération de la france n'a
remis en cause d'indexation des pensions
de retraite sur l'inflation
parce que
remettre en cause l'indexation des
pensions de retraite comme l'a fait ce
gouvernement
en plus de la csg c'est faire diminuer
le pouvoir d'achat des retraités chaque
année mais ces retraités ils ont bossé
on leur vole leur retraite
c'est un contrat social troisièmement
met un peu d'air dans la démocratie
française référendum d'initiative
populaire respect des français arrêtés
des insultes et que le président change
de comportement s'il le peut alors là ça
serait déjà pas mal
vous croyez pas que ça désamorcerait la
pression nicolas dupont aignan vous dit
que vous avez été l'un des premiers à
soutenir ce mouvement à défendre les
gilet jaune vous reprenez leurs
propositions en tout cas vos
propositions sont similaires aux leurs
et pourtant c'est gilet jaune
il ne vous juge pas plus légitime que
les hommes politiques à porter leur
parole est ce que ce n'est pas aussi
votre échec selon vie non mais c'est
normal mais divinisation de la parole
politique et la jour ce que vous
attendez c'est pas possible
j'étais arles j'étais même un soir sur
une barrière de péage sans photographe
bien sûr tout seul avec comme ça en
rentrant de toulon avec un collaborateur
on rentrait de toulon pour aller à une
autre réunion publique à 23h30 je me
suis arrêté j'ai discuté et il y avait
il y avait la france il y avait tous les
partis il y avait toutes les origines il
y avait toutes les professions il disait
qu'il y avait même les gendarmes qui
sympathisait et il disait quoi ils
disaient mais un est ce qu'on va nous
respecter et 1 est ce qu'on va pouvoir
travailler vivre de notre travail de les
prélèvements obligatoires ont explosé en
france
fillon fin de sarkozy hollande
et cerise sur le gâteau macron avec de
surcroît une politique très injuste et
bien c'est l'explosion donc j'ai proposé
crédibilisation la mayral politique de
des crimes et de notation de notre
représentation nationale
c'est normal que les gels et je n'ai pas
envie que monsieur dupont-aignan soit
monsieur gilet jaune
d'ailleurs il ne nous demande rien en
revanche c'est normal que monsieur
dupont-aignan qui est un citoyen qui a
des idées politiques et qui présida
parti fasse son boulot et présent des
solutions mais ils ont pas et si l'on
gouverne entier vous en savez rien
dassier sinon il l'aurait dit mais il
n'ya pas nous n'en attend pas dû
m'éloigner environ- armés dans les
riches ne demande pas de temps il y a
des gens de tout horizon politique quand
il ya eu la révolution française
mission française il n'était pas pour
l'un ou pour l'autre qui vous fait
l'analogie mais oui nous sommes dans un
phénomène pré révolutionnaire et vous
pouvez reconnaître au moins une chose
c'est que ça fait des années que je dis
ça va péter
on peut pas être si injuste tout le
temps je vais vous donner un exemple
tout à l'heure on a parlé du
protectionnisme le protectionnisme
existe en france pour le cinéma français
et l'audiovisuel et le secteur de la
culture
oui mais pourquoi il n'est pas valable
pour les agriculteurs et les ouvriers et
ça je les dis en 2012 en 2010 être
prenais mes phrases 2012 2017
je tire la sonnette d'alarmé depuis des
années mais ça ne veut pas dire que je
suis le représentant du gilet jaune et
je n'ai pas cette prétention député je
cherche à apporter une méthode et je
cherche surtout est ce que le
gouvernement comprenne qu'il ya urgence
question 2 à ce jour en jour là plus on
joue aussi au parlement nicolas dupont
aignan vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure
pas de démission du président de la
république pas dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale pour le moment de
songer à une motion de censure qui va
être déposée par les communistes par la
france a soumis ce qui sera peut-être
soutenue par le parti socialiste et ce
courriel à soutenir cette motion
financière je peux la voter mais fera
pas voter puisqu'ils ont la majorité
donc après vous pourriez la beauté mais
c'est du folklore politiciens tout ça
c'est aussi un signal est envoyé par les
parlementaires mais c'est un signal dans
toute la france fiche éperdument puisque
toute la france est que ce parlement est
tenu par emmanuel macron donc il ya
trois solutions très simples soit
emmanuel macron change de politique
économique et sociale ne fait pas
semblant change de politique économique
est ce c'est la fin du quinquennat
non c'est peut-être sa seule chance de
rester président jusqu'au bout
soit il ne comprend pas et il faudra une
religion team à sion populaire par le
suffrage qui viendra soit de la
dissolution soit sa démission
donc par exécution le débat au parlement
qui aura une au mercredi et jeudi pour
vous il est utile ou pas il va être mais
le parlement ne représente pas la
diversité que l'autre junior française
sur nacre on a la majorité du parlement
donc on va assister à du folklore
politique qui va ne rien changer
la vrai que monsieur gbagbo député vous
êtes en train de nous dire en gros que
le parlement est inutile mais quand
la république en marche à la majorité
absolue à l'assemblée nationale ça fait
un an et demi qu'ils votent comme des
robots les ordres de monsieur macro donc
vous n'est ce que vous croyez ça va
changer
maintenir la pression venue de
l'extérieur on fait la seule solution
la seule solution est ce qu'il faut
aller par exemple comme le propose
olivier besancenot puisque vous dites
que on trouve non les gilet jaune des
gens qui viennent de la droite de la
gauche des extrêmes elles demandent
ensemble est-ce que par exemple l'appel
à la grève générale samedi par olivier
besancenot aurez votre assentiment du
point ma question est celle-ci grève
générale en tout cas au oui/non
je pense que si les syndicats étaient
encore des syndicats si monsieur berger
n'était pas comment dire un syndicaliste
d'opérette
si les syndicats étaient encore des
syndicats s'y tient à l'éthique mais de
la plupart des partis politiques je suis
d'accord avec vous et bien il y aurait
eu un soutien et peut-être que la crise
se serait dénuée plus vite mais ma
question n'était pas celle ci portait
sur une grue jaune et moi je ne vais pas
porter des jugements sais rien je vais
réfléchir
en tout cas ce que je sais c'est
qu'après trois semaines de fortes
pressions d'un peuple dans sa diversité
très pacifique
n'en déplaise des images qu'on a voulu
mettre en boucle pour déconsidérer les
français est ce que vous croyez que je
ne condamne pas les vieux non mais ça va
mieux en le disant
je les condamne totalement et je suis
même un des rares cas d'y aller au champ
de mars ne l'est pas aux champs elysées
et j'ai toujours marine le pen a commis
une erreur quand elle a appelé le
gouvernement à demander à ce que les
champs elysées soir attention je ne
dirais pas du mal de marine le pen pour
eux le faire les mêmes vous êtes
finalement d'escale bien elle a dit à
l'époque allait ouvrir les
champs-elysées qu'importe
moi j'ai vu que c'était un mouvement
provincial pacifique d'hiver et je pense
que là le pouvoir le gouvernement doit
en tirer
sont soit il en tire les leçons
rapidement à grande échelle et un choc
de confiance et un choc fiscal pour
redonner de l'air la production en
france
soit nous partirons dans le décor et
j'en suis inquiet c'est maintenant la
balle est chez le président de la
république vous emmener sur table parce
que vous assumerez peut-être un jour une
part de responsabilité dans ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui sur le plan économique
car monsieur vaqueront qui doit
uniquement l'entière responsabilité de
sa politique il a il y à des pertes
économiques qui commençait très will
milliards d'euros je lui demande
d'arrêter de bloquer la france c'est
monsieur macron par sa politique son
mépris son incompétence est en train de
bloquer la france je lui je le je lui
demande d'être un président de la
république qui affronte l'histoire qui
ne soit pas le marie-antoinette de la
vème république
est-ce que vous pensez que dans tous les
cas de figure le président la république
pourra poursuivre son programme et ses
réformes mais certainement pas ces
réformes entre guillemets qui sont
prendre l'argent des classes moyennes
pour le donner une minorité retraite à
l'assurance chômage à la révision
constitutionnelle vous pensez que ça un
avenir ça ou pas je ne crois pas je
crois que au jour d'aujourd'hui il y à
un pays qui souffre
il y a une politique qui est injuste ils
ont trop tiré sur la corde
il faut revoir complètement la politique
il faut revoir le fonctionnement de
l'union européenne
car derrière cela il ya c'est évident
une crise européenne majeure il ya des
élections qui se profilent oui mais on
ira jusqu aux élections et le cas niko
non je vais vous dire alors très claires
j'ai maintenant terminé ma frange et
bien vous alors à les yeux mais j'écoute
votre réponse d'abord non j'attends la
fin de votre question on se dit on à un
chef de parti évidemment qui dit voile à
l'ag
les gros sur les gilets jaunes car mon
objectif c'est d'être très puissant aux
élections européennes on vous place déjà
dans les sondages à 6% s'est élevé et
peut-être que dans votre tête
secrètement vous allez nous le dira
regardez moi je voudrais que vous
entendez cola dupont aignan je serai là
surprise
eh bien je vais vous dire j'ai
conscience de la gravité de la situation
je ne sais même pas si le président la
république va aller jusqu'aux
européennes
donc là je veux dire que compte tenu de
leur conscience de ce qu'il a fait
pendant trois semaines de cette
incapacité à réagir je m'inquiète et je
ne souhaite qu'une chose pour mon pays
c'est qu'ils prennent conscience de ce
qui se passe en pays et qu'ils agissent
je n'ai aucun aucune autre je peux vous
le vous le jurer parce que c'est grave
ce qui se passe et on peut pas jouer
avec un pays inflammables les banlieues
sont au bord de l'insurrection
les classes moyennes n'en peuvent plus
les casseurs sont à l'oeuvre
et vous savez notre pays quand il est
méprisé
ça peut partir mal donc moi je vais vous
dire tout ce que je ferai pour mettre
des propositions sur la table
dire au président saisissez les allez-y
mais si ça part mal c'est quoi je
parlais tout à l'heure en introduction
vous m'avez entendu le pire est possible
puisqu'il une fois la compassion je les
demande déjà si représentative il ya des
critiques institutionnel de plus en plus
vives et je souhaitais quoi plus on a ce
talent va mal par value on attend ce
sera quoi plus la situation va pourrir
je ne veux pas qu'il y ait dans mon pays
que j'aime eu des champs elysées bis en
province j'apprenais lac à toulon il y
avait des des racailles qui est en train
de piller des boutiques
je ne veux pas de cette politique du
pire qui te semble désirer
inconsciemment ou consciemment le
président de la république je lui dis
solennellement vous êtes président de la
république vous avez en charge un pays
qu a eu la révolution cancer vous croyez
que les ex en 48 kg est un pays qui est
à bout vous n'avez pas compris ce que
vous veniez vous croyez vous êtes en
crise vous voyez que c'est ultra et ces
casseurs sur les champs elysées
il demande du pouvoir d'achat en plus
vous croyez que 150 ils ont été bien
bien favorisé par le gouvernement c'est
le gouvernement qui a laissé faire ça
bien sûr pour déconsidérer le mouvement
et je pense que le gouvernement a été
débordé et que il ya un mélange
d'incompétence et de cynisme on a déjà
eu le cas au premier mais souvenez vous
il faut envoyer l'armée l'a
éventuellement ça nous allait faire
tirer l'armée entre le peuple français
moi rien il faut tendre la main
il faut tendre la main au peuple
français à ceux qui travaillent aux
artisans aux commerçants à ceux qui font
la richesse du pays à ceux qui osent
infirmières dans les hôpitaux
il faut cesser le mépris de classe
première étape vous lui demander de se
changer lui-même
si on vous suit soit il change soit le
peuple changera voilà sauriol est ce que
cette crise politique institutionnelle
sociale elle va changer la nature de
l'élection européenne
est ce que vous allez en faire un
référendum pro ou anti emmanuel macron
mais on n'en est même plus loin je ne
sais pas comment on va arriver au mois
de juin je n'en suis même pas là je
souhaite que notre pays est vite une
crispation pseudo à zurich sionnel
malsaine qui quand elle commence on ne
sait pas comment elle s'arrête et j'ai
le culte de l'état
je crois à l'ordre et pour qui est de
l'ordre dans un pays fragile il faut
qu'ils aient de la justice c'est tout et
je ne mettrais voilà je ne peux pas vous
dire mieux
j'ai fait des propositions maintenant la
balle est dans le camp du président de
la république je ne suis pas présent
arrêt que vous voyez un parallèle entre
ce mouvement d gilet jaune et ce qu'on
voit en italie avec mouvement 5 étoiles
notamment le brésil avec trump le
problème de la france et qui a pas eu
depuis le référendum de 2005 qui a été
bafouée par l'oligarchie politique les
français ont dit leur vérité en 2005
rien n'a changé ensuite vous avez une
élection nicolas sarkozy qui a donné un
grand espoir
nicolas sarkozy s'est couché face à
madame merkel et puis françois hollande
qui prétendait combattre la finance il
s'est mis à plat ventre devant madame
merkel et bruxelles et puis il ya les
manuels macron qui parce qu'il était
jeune nouveau
a donné un grand espoir à beaucoup de
gens qui sont dit assez plus les vieux
politique on va changer mais rien ne
changeait sur le fond ce qu'il faut
c'est protéger la france de
l'immigration qui nous coûtent très cher
e de la délinquance de donner un coup de
pouce à ceux qui bossent par exemple que
le rsa quand on reçoit le rsa on doit
donner une journée par semaine selon moi
à la collectivité une politique du
travail du mérite
protéger notre pays redynamiser les
forces vives
voilà ce que je propose maintenant soit
le président la république on prend soin
il reste dans son château aussi le
comprend à vos yeux est ce que vous êtes
prêts à une forme d'union nationale ce
sera notre dernière question à une forme
de respect et d'union nationale on verra
en tout cas déjà qu'ils comprennent
qu'il faut changer de politique
économique et que donc il faut revoir
tous les engagements de bruxelles et
dire à nos chers partenaires c'est fini
on ne joue plus à ce mauvais jeu qui est
en train de mettre la france à feu et
est ce que vous de vous demander à être
reçu par le chef de l'état avec ou sans
caméra sans caméra sans caméra la banda
des coups mais ramé 115 accepter sa
carrière si emmanuel macron avait un peu
d'audace il recevrait avec des caméras
l'ensemble des leaders politiques ils
créeraient des états généraux de la
fiscalité
il prendrait l'initiative merci d'avoir
été avec nous nicolas dupont aignan
c'est la fin de cette audition publique
merci de notre invitation et la semaine
prochaine notre invité sera gérard
larcher le président du sénat a très
vite très bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]
c'est le temps fort de l'actualité du
parlement le gouvernement face aux
questions des députés
présenté par brigitte boucher à 14h
questions d'actualité interview duplex
reportage pour un panorama complet avant
d'entrer dans l'hémicycle
la séance est ouverte à 15 heures les
questions au gouvernement en direct et
en intégralité et à 16h le débrief
prolongement de la séance en compagnie
de deux députés
votre grande session d'actualité
parlementaires à l'occasion des
questions au gouvernement présenté par
brigitte boucher c'est demain à partir
de 14 heures je suis journaliste
j'ai passé plusieurs semaines en
république islamique d'iran
nous revenons en arrière ne progressons
pas cette vie souterraine me fascine
leur liberté s'y risquer leur révolte
une partie de la jeunesse iranienne et
toof et n'hésitent plus à braver les
interdits dans son pays de quoi menacer
l'avenir du régime des mollahs nous en
débattons avec mes invités droit de
suite présenté par jean-pierre gratien
demain 20h30